bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors une première action
après l annonce de la mise en examen du
ministre de la justice
la honte la honte
un ministre bise en examen et tu ne
démissionne pas ayant puisqu'elle le
soutien du premier ministre et du
président de la république donc c'est
pour moi c'est la honte alors déjà pour
le cnct air france police policiers en
colère on va rajouter donc une place
supplémentaire donc vous venez d'en
parler pour la violation du secret de
l'instruction
pour aussi une diffamation et là c'est
prescrit donc on pourra pas déposer
plainte non plus donc j'invite vos
téléspectateurs avoir sur touche pas à
mon flic sa chaîne youtube
nous démontrons que monsieur dupont
moretti a violé le secret de
l'instruction dans la fierté aux donc
voilà la honte
la jurisprudence balladur monsieur
dupont morice il n'a jamais été vraiment
un ministre il est resté avocat ce n'est
pas un homme d'état on a acquis retourne
dans les prétoires puisqu'il fait
vraiment content à la république ils ont
à la france alors on le rappelle à votre
syndicats déposent plainte contre eric
dupond-moretti pour violation du secret
de l'instruction et violation du secret
professionnel dans le cadre de la ferté
haut
expliquez-nous ce qui a motivé votre
plainte alors nous travaillons avec avec
deux maîtres farrugia de nice nous
travaillons sur cette affaire depuis
longtemps son affaire théo puisque
monsieur dupont maurizi encore un confit
d'intérêt et le et avocats de 2 théo bon
c'est passe énormément de choses sur
cette affaire monsieur dupont moretti
arrivée sur le plateau de clics en 2018
sur canal+ et à déballer le secret
d'instruction l'addeva lixon dépasse
d'un viol mais c'était pire qu'un viol
voilà donc j'invite vraiment aux
téléspectateurs à regarder la vidéo
qu'on a été surprise par murphy coup on
démontre vraiment quelles instructions
en tant qu'avocat il ne respectera pas
la loi puisque diffamé la police en
disant que nous avions fuite et fait
fuiter certaines choses donc c'est déjà
le bol le ministre des voyous c'était
l'avocat des boyaux ce ministre n'a rien
à faire en tant que ministre qui
retournent dans les prétoires et qu'il
arrête de faire honte à la france en
avez-vous désormais de bon
espoir que votre plainte aboutisse après
cette récente mise en examen
j'espère bien en tout cas avec mettre
fin au budget on travaille ardemment
dessus mais on va se battre on va se
battre toute façon un ministre doit
respecter la loi c'est un justiciable
comme les autres
monsieur dupont moretti ne l'a pas
respectée en tout cas la diffamation
l'atteinte à la présomption d'innocence
à les caractériser en regardant cette
émission est de surcroît la violation du
secret d'instruction en plus donc voilà
j'espère que notre plainte va être
entendu et qui sera à nouveau mise en
examen mais de toute façon je pense
qu'il lui reste un an à faire j'espère
que toutes ses affaires entre les trois
cent mille euros aussi qu'il a oublié de
déclarer
voilà monsieur dupont moretti s'est
vraiment les knicks trop d'hollande
bruno attal merci en tout cas d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire national syndicat
france police votre syndicat qui a
déposé plainte contre l'actuelle garde
des sceaux on la prie tout à l'heure qui
a été mis en examen merci à vous